thanks so much thanks everyone for
coming um
super super happy to be here virtually
um you know so this is my
version of the stanford uh uh classroom
um so this is columbia's hybrid we call
it high flex
uh teaching setup so let's see let's see
how it works
um so yeah so um
today uh we we generally think of
accessibility
in terms of uh in terms of providing
access
right how to make experiences and places
uh possible for people with disabilities
in this talk i'm going to show
how we can go beyond just thinking about
accessibility in terms of access
and you know not just making experiences
and life possible
but rather uh making them have a similar
or equivalent experience
as people without disabilities get to
enjoy so that'll be the subject of this
talk
uh we're i'm going to cover two areas
which is one is blind accessible video
games
and then the second is audio navigation
tools for pedestrian navigation
and the first is going to be informing
the second we're going to draw a lot of
insights from video games from virtual
spaces digital spaces
that will help us understand how to make
the physical world
uh more navigable um and and provide an
equivalent experience to people with
visual impairments
so my lab michael mentioned this already
but my lab is the computer-enabled
abilities lab
let me just get my clicker on focus here
there we go computer enabled abilities
lab or seal for short
and we are looking to you know the type
of work that we do is we make it so that
computers can grant people abilities
the ability to better experience the
world and so
there are four threads of i guess skills
that we employ
in our research one is accessibility of
course
second is machine learning we like to
think about like what is what does it
mean like how can you
model experiences so that you know that
uh
you know one you can say definitively
that one person is having an equivalent
experience
we look at inputs for example controller
inputs
vr ar inputs and how we can actually
model those probable
probabilistically we look at games
we wear a game design hack quite often
in our approaches as you'll see here in
this talk
and we do social computing work um
quite often if you ask people you know
who visually impaired users
people with disabilities you know just
people in general
what do you promote like most value in
life they'll often say like other people
and so social computing is tremendously
important if you think about making
technology grant people abilities
a lot of the work that i do at snap i'm
a research scientist there snap which
makes snapchat
is involved in social computing as well
and so you'll see later we're talking
you know
we'll be talking about maps and sharing
maps social computing will come in
so this talk itself is really going to
be focusing on the accessibility angle
and the games and how
and the mix between the two as i
mentioned before we're going to be
looking at
digital spaces first and how we can make
digital spaces
equivalently accessible and then that
those principles will inform our
treatment of physical spaces the real
world
okay so um we also tend to you know in
the lab view computers as being
intermediaries
um you know so here's a computer for
example of people's smartphones
and they act as intermediaries between
people
and all of the experiences they want to
have everything they want to get out of
their lives
right so whether that's learning finding
jobs making friends
food all this stuff people funnel their
attention through computing devices
in order to unlock these experiences in
real life
um and so that powers us you know
thinking that computers have the power
to grant people abilities but it's a
double-edged sword
yes computers can grant people abilities
that they otherwise wouldn't have
and that's how a lot of accessibility
researchers view
assistive technology but
computers can also act as gatekeepers uh
right
they can hold the keys hold back the
keys
uh to uh other aspects of the world
based on their representation of that
world
and so they can effectively block people
from participating
in things in an equivalent manner so
that we'll we'll be looking into that as
well
okay and so our mantra is
from making life possible to making life
equivalent
let me show you an example of what i
mean in the physical world
so this is a house in scotland and
one of the children needed a wheelchair
and so this family petitioned the town
to install a ramp for that child
um the town finally did and they
installed this
this is the ramp right here um and you
know so i'm going to show you another
angle from the corner here
so you can see the stairs and then
there's this ramp on the side
while this ramp clearly makes it
possible to enter and exit that building
you know going up that ramp is certainly
not an equivalent experience to just
walking straight up those stairs
the only people that would ever use that
ramp are people who have to
and that's a problem so i'll show you
another example
physical world does anyone here know
what
what this building is
can give a hint has anyone been to this
building
it's in washington dc does that help
so this is so this building is um the
library of congress
it's the world la the world's largest
library and
um the normal route you know uh you know
to enter this building if you don't need
a wheelchair
is up these stairs right over here
through the arches
into this grand lobby here's another
view here's the stairs
you go up the stairs you enter under the
arches absolutely amazing
lobby absolutely beautiful but if you
need a wheelchair
then your entrance is not shown anywhere
in this
in this image actually you have to go
all the way to the end of the block on
your right there's this corner here this
is a google maps view
and then you have to enter right here
next to the guard booth
make sure that the guard sees that yes
you're in a wheelchair
and then you can proceed along the
sidewalk into a lower level of the
library of congress
so again entering is possible um
but it's definitely not an equivalent
experience
so i just showed two examples from the
physical world
this is super super common in the
digital world as well
and so i'm going to be focusing on games
specifically video games an entire new
like
genre of games has opened up called
audio games
and what audio games are are um audio
representations of video games
uh that it's like a
a whole class of games that's made to
simulate what the video version of the
audio games would otherwise be
um interestingly you might see this
glare there's a
building in new jersey across the river
that's perfectly reflecting the sun
right now
i can roll down the window or it'll
probably end in just a few minutes
so anyway so this is audio games
let me show you an example of um of some
of these audio games they do not offer
the same experience
that their respective video game
counterparts do
let me show you an example so this is
color crush most of you have seen it and
essentially
uh you you know you just have it's a
touch screen game you swap uh
you know these uh these candies get
three of a kind and then you
um and you clear them so i'll just throw
some video
color crush so there's some color crush
action everyone's seen color crush
um so uh an audio game version of color
crush has
come out um by a hobbyist you know which
is great it's better than nothing
um you know i i admire that a lot
but let me show you blindfold color
crush
that's what it's called uh which is uh
the the audio the audio game equivalent
of color quest just so you can see
if you happen to be blind or visually
impaired you don't get to play this
you're going to play this other game so
here it is
blue green yellow
red green blue white
so could you hear that audio by the way
sort of okay um so the sounds
um uh essentially was just announcing
colors
as the person swiped um uh
in in this right so they're saying blue
green yellow blue
white right this is blindfold color
crush
um and then i think uh a two finger
swipe
swaps that's and so this is just a ui
view but the player is blind so they
won't they won't be seeing this
clearly this is not the same experience
as playing
uh color crush right um clearly not the
same
uh it's right like you know color crush
is a very
zen-like experience
there's a lot of submission in game
design terms this is all wrote like
memorization
very very different type of game
so let me show you another example right
so actually you know one point from that
from that example is that um merely
providing
all of the visual information and
conveying that
in this audio game clearly doesn't do it
you can't just make sure that the player
has all of the audio information
that doesn't quite uh cut it so here's
another uh example which is a game
called top speed three
um this is a very successful um and
great actual
actually racing game audio racing game
that's designed to
give people who are blind the ability to
play
some kind of racing game so let me just
show you some gameplay from
top speed three by show i mean sound
remember there are no graphics um let me
uh
have you listen to a clip of that and i
it's important that you hear this so let
me just see
okay so here's the game
all right so i think this is the best
that we're going to be able to do in
terms of the sound
okay yeah there are no visuals it's all
it's all sounds
unfortunately um okay so
yeah so so what you heard i'll just
explain um as as the game was playing
was the game was announcing
left right left hard left easy left easy
right
left hard left crash um and so the
player's goal there
was actually just to react to the turns
um and to react quickly
and that was and that essentially was
the racing game but it doesn't really
feel like racing right there's several
problems here
one is that it's just a test of reaction
speed naturally
the second is that there's no real track
uh no actual track simulated in the game
or vehicle physics it's a very
simplified version
of a racing game and so this you're
going to see this time and time again
with audio games
and so i'd like to ask the following
research question which is
is it possible to make existing video
games blind accessible
rather than creating this new class of
you know
separate and not quite equal games audio
games
can we make existing video games
playable by both people who are sighted
and people who are blind who want to
play that same game
and so just to you know move towards
this answer i'm going to present
a project of mine called the racing
auditory display or the rad for short
and what this what this project was was
it was an audio system
designed um to be used for a standard
pair of headphones
that makes it possible for people who
are blind to play the same types of
racing games as
sighted players can with the same speed
and sense of control that
sighted players have and so so i'll go
into the design of this system and and
some of the insights that we got from it
um i collaborated on this with my former
phd advisor uh sri nair
at columbia and but before i do that let
me just uh
you know i showed blindfold color crush
i showed top speed three
why racing games in particular um we're
interested in finding general principles
or or methods for uh strategies
for making uh games in general blind
accessible
right but we started with racing games
and there are two reasons why
number one in a racing game they're only
you know
it's both easier and harder they're
easier and harder
one it's easier because uh racing games
only have a certain like a small amount
of information
um that the player needs to know and be
aware of at any given time so it's
it's an easier test you know test ground
test bed for that purpose
um but then two it's harder because
racing games move
it's really important to communicate
that information in real time
the player doesn't get to just like
pause think about things make another
move
you want to keep it moving so that it
feels like racing you don't even want to
slow the game down
because racing is all about speed so how
do you communicate all the information
that needs to be communicated
in real time was a real challenge so
speaking of challenges right
conveying the visual information that's
challenge number one
how do you convey that using uh sound or
you know not visuals um two we
do that while preserving the game's
tempo it has to
be moving at the same speed to still
feel like racing
three even though you're trying to
convey a lot of visual information
how do you do that without overwhelming
the player with sounds
and four last challenge is we wanted to
use standard hardware
uh no fancy you know body worn stuff um
just a regular pair of headphones and
maybe the rumble motors within a
standard video game controller
so that this like solution could be
generalized to and deployed on consoles
and pcs
um so the reason why we thought that uh
you know that that
problem of blind accessible games could
be tackled
is um is kind of from wearing our game
designers hat so in game design
it's um you know pretty widely known and
this is spoken about at
game developers conference all the time
um that
um so so a lot of folks including mark
leblanc here that who i cite um
ask the question what do players get
out of video games what aspects of games
are fulfilling for players in what ways
are people fulfilled
by games that they play so that's what
this quote this thing is here which is
like eight types of fun
um what kinds of fun if you were to
split up that term
um and not make it overloaded what would
that look like in terms of what players
are getting out of games
and so that includes things such as
discovery submission
so can't candy crush um you know and
color crush
submission uh challenge fantasy etc
these are
like this is breaking down in terms of
what players get out of games
if you look at these only one of them is
heavily dependent
on visuals and that's sensation uh games
as sense pleasure
where like just pretty graphics or
really amazing environments um
themselves can be fun to to explore and
to see
right or like you know oh wow this game
did you feel like the the
you know hd haptics etc hd rumble in
that game that's sensation
only one is visual the rest
um visuals aren't really necessary to
any of these things and that's why
that was the the key insight here like
this is why it should be possible to
make
video games um you know except for
sensation perhaps
blind accessible okay
so ultimately we wanted to create a
real racing auditory display a rad
some kind of audio system that really
feels like racing so players get that
same experience of racing
um as opposed to one of those top speed
type systems which are just announcing
turns
one of these basic auditory displays um
there's an obvious analogy which you can
guess
so our approach um to to making this
happen um is to
as i said with the library of congress
example you know so that's where this
comes back
um is to replicate the experience and
not just the visual information
more specifically uh experiences are
based on
meaningful choices that people make um
and this is also
pretty common knowledge in in game
design right uh
players make meaningful choices from
moment to moment and that constitutes
their experience in the game
and their feeling of agency when playing
the game and so by replicating the
meaningful
choices from moment to moment that
players are making
uh in terms of the audio cues so that
you can design the audio cues such that
they give players the same input
information
to make those same decisions that's when
you that's the secret sauce
so let me just be a little more specific
here
so in terms of racing game our actual
approach to solving this problem and
making it
blind accessible making it really feel
like racing is to
race a whole bunch of laps around the
track ourselves
and then almost go you know go back and
watch the replays frame by frame
and really analyze from moment to moment
what are we making our what pieces of
information are we making our steering
decisions
based off of um what is it that we're
just that's making us decide to turn a
little bit left
turn right you know at from moment to
moment that is the information that's
needed to make those meaningful choices
from moment to moment
so it's not important to replicate all
of the visual information here
only the information necessary to
preserve
those meaningful choices that game play
that's the idea and so it turns out with
with
a standard racing game there are two
main uh
choices that a player needs to make or
two uh
rather pieces of information that
players make their
base their steering decisions on number
one
is how the race car is situated on the
track
number two is the nature of upcoming
turns
and so with the rad we designed two
audio cues
to convey those two separate things
so the rad comprises two audio cues
one is what uh you know we call the
sound slider
which communicates the car's positioning
on the track
i'll explain how that works and then the
second is the turn indicator system
and that uh that communicates the nature
of upcoming turns
so let me talk i'll talk mostly about
the sound slider it's a little more
involved spend more time here and then
the turn indicator system
okay so the sound slider the way that i
like to
explain this to uh to players is like
follows
imagine that you're sitting directly
behind the car that you're controlling
so
that you hear the sound of the car's
engine right in front of your face
as you steer left and right you're
controlling that car that engine sound
directly
so it's going to slide laterally in
front of you
in the soundscape in 3d space um in
front of your face
that's the sound slider that that's
essentially the concept
but it raises a really interesting sort
of research question
um if you if you peek behind the curtain
here
uh you'll find that we have this
situation
where right the whole point is to
communicate the cars uh
you know how the car is situated on the
race track the car could be pointed any
given way
it could be oriented any or you know
placed any way
the track could be doing a whole variety
of things there's a lot of rich
information about how the car is
situated here
and we somehow want to use computation
to distill that information
down to some value of x between 0 and 1.
somehow it's almost a dimensionality
reduction that we're trying to perform
so the question here for the sound
slider is like what should the value of
x
be so one naive approach
um first take is um why
doesn't why not use x to communicate the
car's lateral position on the track
the car is over here the slider might
move
you know to match wherever the car is
laterally so if it's in the middle
be in the middle if it's kind of on the
left edge be on the left
it's one idea that idea falls apart a
little bit in this situation
where you have a straightaway followed
by a sharp turn essentially the slider
will stay in the middle and then it'll
very quickly veer to the right
uh so fast like too fast for the player
to even react to it
so there's a problem with that and so
what that means is that
these two situations um you know the car
being
right here at the at the straightaway
versus the car being
centered laterally but right at the
precipice of the turn
um they're actually very different
beasts and so the sound slider should
actually communicate these two things
differently um same as these two
situations
even though these cars are both
laterally towards the left
if once you point the car towards one
edge
you have a very different right you're
in a very different situation and so
maybe the sound slider should reflect
that
ultimately it's about the relative
risk of hitting either edge of the track
that's the key
insight it's the relative danger here so
for example right in this car
or in this scenario what we end up doing
is
calculate the risk of the car hitting
the left or right edge
based on the lengths of these
trajectories if the car was just
if the player was to steer left how long
would it take to hit the left edge
and likewise for hitting the right edge
that will represent the car's relative
risk of hitting either edge of the track
at that point in time
so if we think about that um
we can actually set x to this value
which is just the ratio
between these arc lengths it's pretty
pretty simple here
and so let's look at these scenarios
again this car that's right in the
middle
the arcs have the same length but this
car that's on the right right the left
arc is going to swoop around the turn
it's much longer than the right arc
and so the it should be communicated
very differently the car is at great
risk of hitting the right edge
same with this scenario um so the left
arc is a lot shorter in this case um but
the left arc is a lot
longer in this case and so we'll be
communicating that risk very differently
so that's the sound slider it's like
communicating the positioning of the car
on the racetrack
in terms of its relative risk of hitting
either side
but that will be complemented by the
turn indicator system that other piece
of information
which is the nature of upcoming turns so
the way that the turn indicator system
works
is is is as follows so it communicates
the
uh direction the sharpness the length
and the timing of upcoming turns uh the
way that it works uh
as a player is approaching a turn
they'll hear an announcer
announce the number so for example they
might say eight for turn eight
uh just to help the player with memory
remember the turns
um and then at the same time they'll
hear a series of four
beeps from either from either ear it'll
sound like
coming from one side or the other if
it's a right turn it'll come from the
right side if it's a left turn it'll
come from the left side
the um the pitch of the beats indicates
the sharpness of the turn
and we uh you know we have three
different turn sharpnesses
um the reason there are four beeps is
that they establish a rhythm
so that uh the turn itself will always
start on the fourth beep
so as the player approaches the turn
they know exactly when the turn is going
to start they know the timing
and then that last beep that
continues sounding as long as the player
is
is in the turn
so so that's how the the sounds uh the
turn indicator system works
and so together the sound slider and the
turn indicator system actually
uh support the following actions in in
the racing game
um they help the player understand their
current speed learn the layout of the
track
cut corners position the car for an
optimal turn
even advanced maneuvers such as choosing
an early or late apex you can do
all of these things with just those two
audio cues and in fact we had
people who are who have been blind their
entire lives try out um the rad
and by the third lap they were able to
actually uh
do a lot of these advanced stuff like
cut corners and and things like that
so i think next up i'm going to show a
quick
video of the rad in action i'm going to
move and try to move my personal
lapel mic closer to the sound source so
you can hear it
[Applause]
[Music]
so you weren't hearing stereo but it's
uh it's stereo sound is spatialized
um and then i'll play a short clip from
that player
uh describing his experience playing
a racing game a real racing game for the
first time
so that particular player was blind uh
has been blind from birth
um sorry before that
a couple data points that's coming after
the data
um in terms of lap times uh we actually
found that the
rad um offered uh you know players were
able to drive laps
in a comparable amount of time as
sighted
casual players um
and then and like in shorter times than
a system that just called out turn left
turn right left
right that's what the red thing is um
and then this one chart before i show
that other video
here are some actual driving paths uh so
the rad is in blue
and then the turn left right left kind
of system is in red
as you see and you can see that the rad
allows the player to actually make some
advanced racing maneuvers right so like
obviously they're going straighter along
this straightaway
but then they can thread the needle in
this s-turn
for example and this was after just
using the rad for a few laps they're
able to
uh form that intuition of what's going
on with the track
okay so here's the video
it was interesting to try
the rad because of the the new
experience that he
gave to me as a visually impaired person
in relation to playing racing games this
feeling of i guess you can say the
feeling of adventuring that it gave the
sense of control that it gave me as a
player
was totally different than what you
would
usually get from other
audio racing games that were
specifically designed for
the visually impaired community
so um the sound slider and the turn
indicator system have some implications
um uh
you know beyond games um to hci in
general
so for example like in a pedestrian
navigation system
uh they can actually be used to help
people who are blind
um walk along a path and not only just
walk follow a straight line along the
path but understand the path's width
and maybe keep to the right side of that
path uh
the way that sound sliders are defined
they're essentially these line segments
in
in 3d space in the soundscape they could
be used to
as slider displays in general in general
purpose uis
um and then they can be used for any
kinds of
steering tasks in the classical sense um
to help some kind of uh you know user
make a motion
through some type of path or tunnel
cool so um that work the
racing auditory display um showed us
that
in order to enable meaningful
experiences it's important to
preserve uh meaningful choices right
um and so rather like in order to enable
equivalent experiences
it's important to preserve meaningful
choices but the rad only scratched the
surface
racing games is just one game genre
there are a lot of other genres such as
platforming games action games adventure
games rpgs first person shooters etc
and then also the rad uh sort of
revealed the prospect of um
with the pedestrian navigation stuff uh
promoting real world navigation as well
and helping people better understand the
real world as they're navigating as well
and so this is work that we're that's
still in progress
um that we are doing in order to
investigate both of those
both of those realms um new genres of
games so in this case this is an
adventure game an
action adventure game um and then how do
we
uh you know so how do we build uh tools
widgets that can be used across
games and maybe built into uh game
engines
to make these types of games playable
and then can those same widgets also
give people more fulfilling experiences
navigating in the real world so they're
not just following orders
so that's this that's this project um
this is the kind of game that i'm
talking about um there's no sound here
uh but just to illustrate this you know
this action adventure game
you can move around you can break crates
every every great game has to have
crates
um some enemies you can melee uh you can
also fire projectiles um that kind of
things
okay so this um this project is led by
vishnu nair
my first phd student um he's a second
year now
uh and then and as well a team of uh
undergraduate and master's students at
columbia
so let me start by talking about audio
navigation today
um in the real world uh and it
it actually works the same way in
existing uh
like adventure games and first-person
shooters generally
these audio navigation tools act as
guides that users must follow
so the prevailing analogy is that of a
guide dog
where there's some kind of sound or some
kind of tool
that tells the user which way to go and
they just follow it
wherever they're going right that's the
analogy
and so um a few common approaches
one is this concept of audio beacons
it's it's present in this system called
swan from georgia tech
microsoft soundscape which is a really
really cool free
mobile app and the way that it works is
that you essentially the user hears
this audio beacon a siren call
using spatialized sound from some point
in space they
rotate themselves to center the sound
and walk towards it
once they do that another sound will
appear they turn
they rotate and walk towards that one
and then they're just guided along a
polyline some route
to their destination so that's that's
audio beacons
so this is how people who are blind if
they want to use an audio system such as
microsoft soundscape to
uh to navigate to to some place that's
that's how they do it
another approach is um navcog so navcog
came out of
carnegie mellon and ibm um and so rather
than using audio beacons they're using
the navcog employs spoken prompts
which tells the player um or the the
user
uh you know walk 50 meters turn left in
10 meters
okay turn left now keep turning keep
turning okay
that kind of thing so here i'm just
going to play this short video so you
can hear what some of these prompts
sound like i'll step over here
turn around you might be going backward
pro c 25 meters and turn right
okay so that's nav cog
spoken directions instead of beacons and
then third we're seeing really
interesting work this is again from
cmu called cabot and this really
you know goes into this guide dog
analogy
what we have here is a suitcase that um
can can move itself along and it has a
depth camera attached to it
and so this suitcase will actually guide
the user
um and the user simply just kind of
follows the suitcase and it also checks
for obstacles along the way
so here's a quick little video of kabot
so it's kind of tugging the user along
it's kind of dragging the user along
but our observation is that again
when we you know thinking about
equivalent experiences
people who are cited um you know
do not you know navigation is not just
about getting from place from point a to
point b
efficiently right it's about a lot more
it's not just about closing your eyes
and having someone take you there okay
you have arrived
it's about a lot more than that it's
about surveying one's surroundings kind
of knowing where they are
enjoying the space itself the journey
along the way
understanding how items are arranged in
a space forming mental maps
cognitive maps of the space right it's
about a lot more than
search uh this idea of just going from
point a to point b
and so um in short navigation is about
looking around and so if you really if
there's one ability that can unlock
um you know agency and navigation it's
the ability to look around
if you can provide that well then
actually people
users would be able to navigate
themselves in a very fulfilling way
rather than just being guided and so nav
stick is an instrument
for looking around and the way that it
works and and so far we've prototyped it
for
games is it repurposes the right analog
stick
into an instrument for looking around
essentially the user
will tilt the stick in order to look
around in that direction with respect to
them
so if you tilt it to the right you're
checking out your three o'clock if you
tilt it forward it's your 12 o'clock
so you can very very quickly survey
what's around you as you go in the game
most adventure games and first person
shooters reserve the right stick for
camera controls but if you're blind you
don't need the camera
so we can repurpose it into an
instrument for looking around
um it's a simple idea but what's
interesting about this idea
is that it enables on demand
on demand and random access to
directional information
it's on demand because users aren't just
being
spoken to the entire time especially
when they don't want to hear speech or
hear that siren sound
the only time that they'll ever hear a
sound is when they when they tilt the
stick
they get to control that um and it's
random access
because they can they can probe any
direction just by tilting the stick in
that direction there's constant time
to to look around no matter regardless
of direction
so here i'm going to show navstick in
a grocery store environment that we
created
i'll explain why we created this grocery
store in in a minute
it's essentially uh to test navstic
not only in that adventure game context
but also in the context of
real world navigation thinking about
environments in which people might want
to find things
and explore and remember where things
are and compare
items that's the grocery store so here's
nav stick in action
i'm going to move so you can actually
here
okay so that was a quick one
and so we asked a few research questions
around napstick giving people this
ability to look around
in spaces which which surprisingly isn't
present right now
number one how well does knapsack
facilitate different
navigation tasks or purposes right so by
navigation tasks i mean
search getting from point a to point b
but also
exploration forming cognitive maps or
comparison comparing different pathways
we draw from
from psychology here in terms of right
the purpose is
that uh you know navigation being an
overloaded term and there are actually
many different purposes for navigation
so we want to we want to understand how
well navstick serves these different
purposes
if it is going to become an instrument
for navigation a widget
that we use across uis two
we want to understand how well does
nafstick facilitate different navigation
environments
so game environments clutter density
occlusion that kind of thing and then
three how does nafta compare to
menu-based surveying
this idea of just having a hierarchical
menu of
targets that people can select grocery
store items for example
um and you know maybe it's alphabetized
or sorted by distance
so i'll show just a couple of results
here um and number two by the way
how well does nafta facilitate in
different environments this is still in
progress
and we're testing this in that video
that adventure video game
environment so i had six different
navigation tests i won't go into this
but essentially we talk about
exploration search
comparison and even playing games where
agency is
more important in navigation
bi-directional i mean
cases in which knowing the direction of
something is important so for example
i want to remember that the milk is in
this corner of the aisle as opposed to
just in the aisle period
and this is like this video game
environment another one this is an act
this is actually a first person shooter
that we recreated and we found that um
participants
um actually enjoy having both a
menu-based
navigation tool uh to get from point a
to point b
and nav stick to explore and look around
and they make that choice based on
whether they would like to navigate
directionally
whether direction is important and
whether or not
they are for example playing a game and
in the context of a game
where people predominantly preferred
navstic
they preferred this even though they
also agreed that navstick took
a lot of extra effort for the game
actually looking around and doing things
themselves
was the whole point of the game to them
they really enjoyed that a lot
so i'm going to show one more result
about mental maps
um people actually felt that they were
able to form
better mental maps of their spaces with
navstic compared to using a menu and
hearing where these things are from a
menu
and they they agreed very small
confidence interval and then we quizzed
them
we put them in random grocery store
aisles and say you know and said okay so
where's the peanut butter
and we found that people performed much
better
when they were able to explore first
with navstic than when they used the
menu
okay so let me go on into
future work
okay so in the future
um um you know the way that
that uh you know we're thinking about
the next couple of years
and and accessibility at large uh is is
related to maslow's hierarchy of needs
right so this is how i
think about accessibility maslow's
hierarchy starts with basic needs on the
bottom
food water shelter that kind of thing
safety needs
and then it moves on up into
self-fulfillment needs achieving one's
full potential including creative
activities
right if you look at most accessibility
research today
it's down here at the bottom of the
pyramid
really focused on just providing basic
access making things
possible fulfilling basic needs right
you might think of it in terms of
actually this this wedge
where we're fulfilling these basic needs
and a lot of
accessibility work is trying to figure
out other basic needs
that that that need to be fulfilled it's
a continuing journey
so we're kind of just expanding outward
in accessibility research
um but we uh at the lab like and this is
and this is also what i believe uh think
that the future is in
agency right accessible accessibility
system shouldn't just be building
outward and serving more basic needs
of course that's super important but we
need to be thinking about creating
equivalent experiences as well
and not you know creating these glass
ceilings for users
right so the future is building up um in
new york we like to build up
uh and so i think uh and so we're doing
a lot of work
um in terms of uh helping people have
these equivalent experiences and the
sense of agency
and self-worth and this feeling of yes i
did it instead of i'm just following
the system's orders and so with navstick
um you know this is ongoing work again i
showed you the team
um we uh actually prototyped napstick in
this video game
allowing users to you know shoot enemies
walk around we're doing a whole bunch of
experiments there
uh we'll be releasing stuff we want to
make all this stuff open source
here's a top-down view of the kinds of
stuff we're doing with navstick
in adventure games and moving on to
other genres of games
we're also thinking about how to very
quickly communicate the shapes of rooms
and layouts to people um using sound
right you walk into a room or a hallway
if you have sight you can very quickly
perceive the general
this general sense of shape how can we
do that
without sight and then my other phd
student gaurav
jane is leading a project which we're
called calling wearable vision
he has a computer vision background
working with several
you know really talented undergrads and
master's students
in which a user can actually create
their own maps
by wearing a little camera harness so
gaurav is a first-year phd student
so this is still pretty early work but
essentially we're
um uh using slam
and uh the idea is like how do we give
blind users um the power to take
navigation and like map making into
their own hands rather than relying on
building owners
to install maps and bluetooth hardware
and all of that themselves
how can blind users take map making and
localization into their own hands
by creating their own spots and making
slam work for humans and not just
robots at factories right there are a
lot of human factors and ui
issues especially if the user's blind
how do they actually control
how do how do you build this kind of
system so this is the
um uh my you know this is part of the
floor
i'm near my office um gaurav i think
just did one loop and formed this map
and created these little spots along the
way we're also going to we're looking
into this idea going into social
computing of
sharing maps so if i for example created
a map of
my office building and then i have a
visitor who's blind i can say oh i have
a map for that
being right or maybe there's kind of an
open street map
or a project sidewalk for this sort of
thing
okay and one last word this is my last
thing um
about this slide about how accessibility
relates to hci that i'd like to say
um accessibility i feel is like very
central to hci because it forces us to
think
of what's really necessary and what's
really needed
um in the systems that we build right
like what is the core
components um we we have to stay
grounded when we think about
accessibility issues but going forward
i think that like you know we should be
thinking in terms of not just
what's really needed um but in terms of
equity like how can we like in all of
these great systems that we build
how do we make sure that we're not just
making life possible for other people
but equitable for other people
okay so thank you so much for listening
and
happy to take any questions sorry for
the high flex
classroom um you know audio issues thank
you brian
no worries the joys of of uh
zoom and yeah brave new world
uh thank you brian uh the uh so this is
a good
a chance for for questions the uh
there's a form that i've linked to in
the zoom chat that you can ask
panelists feel free to just go ahead and
unmute yourselves and
and dive in um did you want to start and
while i
curate the questions from the from the
from the form
sure if i look this way this is my view
of the computer i can see the gallery
here
so yeah okay cool
um i was a little curious about how
you're thinking
about play testing um
so normally you do many many many rounds
um but of course it can be difficult to
bring in participants so i was wondering
just sort of do you do it yourself
do you wear a blindfold you know because
i
saw that you used them in the last cycle
but that's really
kind of late yeah
yeah um thanks for the question yeah let
me actually make that clear
so um during development and like you
know we're coding something does it work
like we do wear blindfold folds
ourselves just to get a basic feel for
things
but we also host um students in the lab
uh
particularly people with visual
impairments so i have relationships
one of the like so uh several different
you know national
organizations for um you know serving
blind users
are headquartered here in new york um
and so i have relationships with
them we have um you know they sit
alongside us
so we co-design with these users um we
host over the summer as well
and so we've actually learned a lot more
from them
as they've learned from us um and
uh and and so that's how we do things so
like when it comes to just like
debugging something do i think this you
know you're coding it's night time
um you know do i think this is going to
work yeah we'll wear a blindfold we'll
try it out and we've learned to have
some kind of intuition for that because
we've been in this space for a while
um but ultimately uh you know co-design
is what what does that for us
absolutely um and i'm going to sneak one
more in have you explored echolocation
yes echolocation i find it super
interesting
um it takes yeah like i i think we
um at least in that that project that i
showed about communicating room
shape um that's actually what we're
looking at
uh most and like different and different
techniques for um generating echolocated
sounds that's actually the space that
we're exploring
thank you yeah thanks
other panelists do you want to jump in
if not we have questions from
uh from attendees as well yeah um brian
i'm curious
it seemed like most of what you talked
about was auditory
but your last few examples made me
wonder
if um touch approaches um
either a braille oriented you know bump
thing or a vibration thing
with you know a little pad that could be
scrolled and zoomed and whatnot
is also a valuable approach and if
you're doing anything with it
yeah yeah i'm really interested in touch
as well
and like just like you said a braille
sort of thing
you know dealing with limited human
sensory resolution that's a major
challenge
um as well as like speed of of motors
right
um actually making the haptics work i
think for general purpose navigation
real world environments they'll work
just fine
for games especially when the games are
very fast i found that to be a
limitation
in some of the you know me just like
trying things out
um but i think to be perfectly honest uh
one of the uh obstacles that we've had
is um
i'm not working with any students like
neither of my phd students and and
myself like we we aren't into hardware
ourselves
um and so that's actually an area that
we're looking to collaborate in
is like how can we think about haptics
design haptics
uh and also think about multimodal
solutions um
audio and haptics um yeah and then and
especially if there's some general
purpose devices that users can buy like
you buy this
one thing and it can you know uh give
you a lot in terms of you know real
world navigation in many contexts um i i
love that idea
um i i have a question um
in the bio feedback space um
specifically with haptics for example or
even auditory feedback there's a lot of
discussion on the need for
personalization that it's
different how the level of comfort
for that feedback for different people
or even the mental models they have for
that feedback
do you think about personalization or
how do you go about that since so much
of the work you're doing is
conveying all this information through
auditory channels
yeah i i think that that um just
you know reasserts the importance of
multimodal um
i think like i've found it just you know
a lot of the
visually impaired folks that i've worked
with and been spoken to
some of them are really into sound some
of them also many of them actually have
hearing impairments even slight ones
that make sound uh work
you know much less effectively for them
and they'd really prefer haptics
some don't like haptics and so i think
that we should be
aiming to design solutions in both sound
and haptics and allow users to kind of
choose and mix and match
hey brian nice to see you hi
uh i had a couple of questions that uh
you know hopefully won't take too much
time so maybe i can do two
um the first question i had was whether
you've looked at whether these kinds of
tools also help
sighted people because it seems to me
like
having this kind of extra feedback you
know extra in the case of someone who's
sighted would
maybe like improve their experience of a
game and i think that's often the case
when we design
more accessible techniques and tools
that actually everyone benefits
so that's just sort of one question
although obviously that's not the focus
then nor
should it be and the other question i
have is how you think about
the trade-off or the tension between
learning something new that might
you know provide someone with a skill
set that's going to you know with the
time investment to learn is going to
provide them a lot of benefit versus
sort of speed of adoption which makes
them you know in the case of
a racing game it's really cool if
someone can within a few laps
be totally proficient at it but also you
know if it's sort of a more
advanced or more difficult technique you
know maybe speed of adoption is not
really the right metric because it might
take longer to pick up but then actually
be like more effective in the long term
so i'm just thinking about how you
evaluate your tools and think about that
trade-off
yeah so um super quick answer to both to
both questions regarding um
uh so i'll answer the the second one
first about
adoption um i think again that's where
personalization is important right
um and and that begs for future work
right so if you have
one technique that does more or less you
know well but you can learn it quickly
and another one that like works
really really well but it takes a while
to learn is that effort worth the cost
it's kind of like learning a new
keyboard layout
um that just begs further research and
so i think that the jury's still out
on that um but in terms of your other
question like for uh you know people who
don't have visual impairments like how
can these systems benefit
uh sighted people um i think about this
every time i go to penn station
downtown and that's actually one of the
reasons why i'm really
um i uh um if i had to choose like
i choose audio um because it's so easy
to incorporate into earbuds
um and so i think there's a lot of
potential to um
to help people who are sighted just with
earbuds that they
would always like normally uh have in
their ears anyways
yeah especially grocery stores that that
topic comes up all the time as well
all right and i will be the the audience
surrogate uh for the folks who submitted
through the
through the form we definitely had
several questions that you've touched on
um
most most of them had to do with haptic
feedback as a channel so certainly a lot
of excitement around that
um also asked a question about
what are the most difficult genres to
make accessible how do you overcome
these problems
maybe a a way to conceptualize that
question would be to ask you know
what seems what seems on the possibility
horizon and then what kinds of
experiences and fulfillments
seem you know capital h hard that you
know that there are fundamental blockers
there that you see
yeah so the regarding the blockers like
i think
if you go if you look back to that eight
types of fun slide
one type was sensation games is sense
pleasure
any games that really hinge on sensation
that's capital h
hard um and so uh you know color crush
candy
crush all of those variants of the same
type of game right they um
uh those those are mostly submission
um but the mechanic of quickly
identifying swappable
gems or candies or whatnot is highly
highly highly visual
and and so that i would say that's
getting closer to capital h hard
first person shooters um i think very
doable
uh platforming games um uh time pressure
is so immense
um but i think the the real obstacle is
the
games that that rely on sensation
and does this some of these examples
seem to be because
our visual system often operates in
parallel but
our audio system you know like these
like if you get the two different uh
sound streams it's hard to track them
both simultaneously is that what's going
on
here yeah that's that's exactly what's
going on so not only does the visual
system you know operate in parallel in
many different ways
but it also just has a much higher
throughput in general
um and so you're kind of losing both
ways with audio compared to visual
channel okay
all right then uh i think that's what we
got
let's thank our speaker one more time
and uh
thank you for joining us remotely from a
classroom in new york city we all wish
we could be there
uh and we wish you could be here too
thanks so much for joining us
yeah i had a blast thanks so much